[Applaudissements]
chanter un peu trop merci
il est 23 heures 40 dans 20 minutes
on aura fait 10 heures de direct
d'affilée les selles et hélas là on va
se régaler ça s'appelle t pmp les paris
sont non c'est parce qu'il a fallu qu'on
crée de nouvelles émissions pour faire
tousser direct et je pense que celle ci
va vous plaire déjà j'ai plein de gens
que j'aime autour de la table il ya jean
luc ya innovia isabelle ya clipperton ya
thierry moreau ya jean michel maire ya
benjamin castaldi l'a bâillonnée iabloko
et qui est la motivation déjà déjà je
voudrais tous vous remercier d'être là
ce soir parce que les chéris mine de
rien il est 23 heures 40
vous n'êtes pas payé à wabush mans non
non non jamais jamais c'est la règle
d'or est franchement merci d'être là est
ce que vous savez ce que vous allez
faire ce soir jean-luc un pas trop mais
on vous fait confiance
ça démarre mal
oui ça l'est pour peu qu'elles aient ça
démarre mal cauet et toi tu as fait 20
34 35 heures à la radio c'est toi qui
détient le record 1 à la radio et à huy
en direct à la radio c'est mon propre
étude et un record mais 35 36 je sais
plus très bien
35 ans dit j'ai vu l'interview de toi et
tu disais le plus dur c'est demain matin
à mon avis à mon pote de menthe est mort
at the rock mais demain matin direct de
suite
j'aimerais bien avoir des commentaires
sur ma tête est ce que ma tara composent
non ces bouts de matha plus dieu mais là
ça va là non mais il a pour l'instant
c'est le tunisien qui parle c'est à dire
que jose comme je suis je suis assez
basané ah non je suis moi marquer un
show croire mais est-ce que ce qui est
drôle c'est qu'on a l'impression qu'il a
la tête qui fait quelque chose et le
corps fait autre chose même temps s'est
dissocié mai mais c'est possible on va
on va à moi je me sens au top
regardez ouais
allé lècher région nous expliquer ce qui
va se passer ce soir ce soir vous allez
tous affronter en duel
un champion dans une catégorie il va y
avoir du sport il va l'avoir de
l'adresse il va y avoir du slip by avoir
désavoué d'avoir des fruits va y avoir
des kardashian
il va y avoir n'importe quoi dans cette
émission tpm paix les paris sont lancés
je vais demander à gilbert days de venir
me rejoindre dans un instant puisque
avant chaque duel
vous allez devoir parier sur le
vainqueur du duel si vous remportez
votre pari vous gagnez saint pois si
vous remportez votre duel contre le
champion vous gagnez 5 points également
d'accord le chroniqueur sera le plus de
points gagnera le premier forfait au ski
puisque on va partir au ski avec une
partie de l'équipe
le 16 décembre on partira tous au ski
pas tous ceux qui seront qualifiés et le
grand gagnant de ce soir gagnera le
premier forfait pour le ski le grand
perdant lui sera déguisé en réveil et
devra rester avec moi jusqu'à demain
matin 6
déguisé en réveil
et petite contrainte il devra faire
dring dring
à chaque heure écoulée et laura est ce
que vous êtes pourtant d'être là oui
mais le relais le coût du réveil du coup
je sais pas alors il est à votre taille
donc on va damas content d'être là aussi
très content image
ah oui qu'est-ce qui se passe oui la
rentrée m il y aura donc dix duels ce
soir est le premier à me rejoindre
c'est gilles verdez applaudissements
polis gilles on sait vous êtes un grand
sportif
oui malgré chose à part ça se voit non
mais franchement les gars on est tous
d'accord mathieu il ya encore de stores
qui là c'est indiscutable quand javelot
le gars n'est pas des plus grands
sportifs et vous vous êtes lancé dans
une nouvelle discipline
oui absolument qui est le trampoline le
trampo de cramponnage il perdait s'est
lancé dans le trampoline on va découvrir
votre entraînement gilles verdez et
juste après on montrera le duel et on
verra qui va gagner gilles verdez où le
champion regarde
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ma salle c'est chez moi
ici pour mon entraînement quotidien de
trampoline alors ce soir c'est
particulier parce que j'ai un duel dans
ce village de sites mais moi c'est
enfilage de script sur trampoline
quel magnifique bel et bien d'un filage
de sites sur trampoline c'est pas
compliqué il faut trois choses un
trampoline vous l'aviez deviné des slips
aussi et beaucoup d'amour
c'est pour ça que c'est un peloton pas
taper des balles ensemble
[Musique]
vous allez
les fausses votez pour moi je
regretterai pas aller au delà
[Musique]
pas grave
oui
oui merci
oui cette émission va démarrer fort il
fallait que pendant ces trente cinq
heures et y ait du slip et bien il y en
a dès le début de cette émission les
chéris vous allez devoir parier entre
notre champion jonathan qu'elle a peu
d'histoire que jonathan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je l'attendais pour moi
[Applaudissements]
il est beau jeu n'a pas merci jonathan
qui est avec nous jonathan vous arrivez
donc à sauter directement dans un slip
grâce à des saltos meilleur ubermedia
des championnats du monde
mais comment vous est venue l'idée de
sauter dans un train a compris en fait
un jour vous mettiez votre site je vais
bien sûr il sait quoi qu'à moi mon
chiffre d'affaires un peu de salto l'a
pas dit non mais comment comment vient
l'idée proposer de faire l'émission je
me suis entraîné réf
ah c'est vrai en fait l'idée de la
démission merci tu t'es cru chez sa mère
non mais les gars on est dans la seule
chaîne l'athlé je suis le seul quand
même animateur ou tu as quand même une
meuf d'user du public des bas mais j'ai
déjà des coques gênant mais si des poids
lourds de la télévision je passe pour un
coût des collèges et des gas et des
tauliers quoi ces gens lui et ouais j'ai
écrit j'ai castaldi ggp d'alim je
rigolais ggb naim
non mais vous ça vous est déjà arrivé
sakho et benjamin comme ça ouais ah non
moi j'avais franchement sûreté gens sont
plus envie en tout cas on march eric on
veut virer
non mais sur tf1 et les gars comme ça
qui vous tapez sur les mollahs n'ont
jamais mari ça n'arrive pas en tout cas
jonathan merci d'être là jonathan vous
allez être confronté à gilles verdez à
votre avis qui va faire le plus attendu
qui va faire le plus de saut à skis vous
aurez 90 secondes chacun chacun notre
tour on a démarré que jonathan
jonathan lui seront salto direct amazing
perdait ce sera sur un trampoline
attention à qui va en faire le plus
parce que c'est plus facile
ah bah ça qui va enfiler le plus de
slips le champion où j'ai dû perdre aide
allez-y beauté là l'explication n'a pas
changé grand chose
quoi vous dites chroniqueur marc clamens
est le seul et sur un malentendu tant
rêver
belga elles gardent bandaman blessure
faite garde de ne pas finir on met bas à
caen jeu direct toute la nuit
je vous rappelle que si vous avez fait
le bon pari et vous pariez d'ailleurs
chez vous sur twitter hashtag des pmp
paris ou je sais pas quoi mais en tout
cas les grilles vous gagnez un point 1
voilà c'est le micro est là c'est ma
fille de carter les vexer et transparaît
d'accord très bien apparemment c'est mon
micro voilà qui déconne mais tout fout
l'camp
la chérie donc vous êtes le seul
benjamin à parier sur gilles verdez
imbéciles on est si vous gagnez bien
mais sans cette loi rien exactement
d'accord si vous avez la bonne réponse
vous gagnez 5 points si vous avez la
mauvaise ont marqué zéro point je vous
rappelle le premier gagnera à la fin de
la soirée son ticket pour le ski et le
dernier sera on réveille avec moi
jusqu'à 6 heures du matin on va démarrer
par jonathan jonathan 90 secondes on va
voir combien de slips vous enfilez vous
le faites juste là ça va vous avez la
place ou pas ouais ça devrait aller ça
va aller ça valide on n'aura pas trop si
c'est mes deux collègues madrik et
maxime d'accord mavericks mavericks et
maxime venez nous voir mavericks et
maxime afrique mavericks et maxime donc
qu'ils sont là pour tenir les slips ils
foncent à toute la journée 1
c'est leur boulot sont des spécialistes
attention gilles venez me rejoindre
on va partir pour 90 secondes est ce que
michael est ce qu'on peut se mettre vous
plaît pas vous pouvez rentrer sur le
plateau rentrée a vu un
merci les cherry on se met en place 90
secondes comme scribe at il confié après
ce sera gilles verdez sur un trampoline
c'est parti on y va aller
il se met en place un galet donc les
slips man vous êtes prêt on lance le
chrono éviter le claquage
bravo handicap et rodriguez se sent que
ça va être bien ça allait attention
c'est parti 90 secondes
[Applaudissements]
holy 06 attention
allez allez allez fiables les plus
attention mathieu bélie trouve quand
même des bons modèles de suivi par aulas
alors attention et bien fait attention
on fait attention je n'attendais pas
vous mais c'est quand même un clip les
changements seraient 50 secondes d'ogier
agneau jonathan attention il reste 30
secondes
attention à l'éviter changement explique
micheline change de slip aussi vite que
nos chances des blues soul music new
delhi mais bon s'organiser je vous fais
attention il reste treize secondes ya
3,8 pour l'instant
[Applaudissements]
ça marche elle en aura pas de soi
perdre s il ya bravo je l'attends et
bravo à vos compatriotes
il y a donc quatre clips 5 pour jonathan
et l'a46 jonathan vous êtes vous êtes
combien de votre corps peut donner suis
[Rires]
pas forcément pas forcément il y a donc
quatre slip à battre benjamin castaldi
est le seul à avoir parié sur gilles
verdez qui va donc avec qui vous allez
bosser j slip
j'ai une assistante j'ai oublié son
prénom elle est adorable ont trahi leurs
clients beaucoup d'années ensemble
est ce que j'ai le droit juste à 15
secondes d'échauffement au rang de
démarrer le train aux médias sociaux
plai il a le droit il a le droit à de
faire un petit peu de trampoline égal
mettez vous sur le côté pour regarder
l'artiste alors allez-y
mettez vous sur trampoline et ne prenez
pas de risque ne vous n'allez pas vous
pétez nez ça va coûter cher ça gilles
verdez attention alors vous êtes avec
votre ami donc comment ça va se passer
donc allez-y ah non mais on vous entend
pas donc on vous regarde donc vous allez
devoir réaliser les ai fait des sceaux
d'avoir fait des sauts je le sens pas du
tout enfant 90 secondes 10 de voix et va
devoir enfiler +24 slip
s'il ya égalité tout le monde a perdu
mais quelle souplesse d'accord à ouidah
à wollega si vous nous rejoignez le
tableau arrière
attention ces bons gilles attention
attention attention n'allez pas vous
blesser j'ai parlé c'est parti pour 90
secondes
et ah oui ah non non
attention c'est l'équipe du dromadaire
d'avant on voit c'est quoi cette taille
c'est castaldi gagné l'égalité vous avez
50 secondes pour battleship
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non non non non quarante secondes à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout est allé vite
c'est bon et au bout du rouleau et les
invités le père aulas et jonathan
gilbert c'est je crois qu'il faut je
crois qu'il faut faire le slip en or oui
on va être obligés de les départager
et ça c'est d'une configuration sur une
configuration que je n'avais pas
envisagé il ya donc quatre slip partout
à jonathan et gilles vous allez donc
vous départager
vous allez donc vous départager au
chiffon me away renée la jeune et la
peep et apel et pierre feuille ciseaux
puisque vous avez fait 4 slip partout il
n'y en a qu'un cas miser sur gilles
verdez s'ils gagnent ce chiffon me
benjamin castadi vous prenez l'avantagé
aux rennais s'aggrave et tout le monde
est à 0 déjà il lui donne un conseil
tomber le coup n'a aucun conseil
le gars il faut donner des conseils au
sujet il va la fermer on est à la télé
quand même mais on a la télé a tenté un
coup gagnant mains derrière le dos
jonatan gil chifoumi attention chine
fou mais je suis en couple à faire
sécher
[Applaudissements]
non
bakaba
gagné
benjamins
donc on en restera donc cinq points pour
gilles et 5 points pour benjamin pour
les autres merci maintenant et merci
merci et il n'y a pas de risque que ça
devienne une discipline olympique
qu'est ce qu'il ya y a pas de risques ça
en tout cas il n'ya pas très ce que vous
devenu humoriste la drogue
on est peut-être ont-ils là dessus les
chiffres tout cas benjamin et qui est le
seul à avoir parié sur vous gilles on va
vous équiper dans un instant son vous
pouvez le faire
et est ce que j'y laisse que gilles vous
a impressionné surtout il aura très
belle technique les gracieux en plus
ohlala non vraiment moss petit petit
pâquerettes mokhtar ab performance de
génois ouais c'est vrai c'est pas mal
merci jean luc j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un
aussi à l'aise avec son slip
[Rires]
bon il y en avait un qui était à fond il
avait d'ailleurs c'est pas comme un écho
et non mais benjamin échos et on
al'impression on avait l'impression
qu'ils jouaient leur vie ouais ouais non
mais qu il était comme un fou quoi mais
parce que excusez moi il ya eu deux
trois clips faut un papa côté
passionnant on a été intransigeant avec
vous un franchement avec vos slips
savage il pas trop fatigué ces
disciplines que vous allez continuer ou
bien vous allez arrêter d'accord j'adore
ça suivant il ya quand même une personne
qu'on n'a pas entendu depuis le début
d'émission et qui est comme ça depuis
des munitions et maman allait voir moi
c'était très bien merci
eh bien le prochain nos prochains défis
ça va être un défi sportif
encore un défi sportif et il va falloir
quelqu'un de très musclé sebo k à aa
alors oui pour le prochain défi
on va tenter quelque chose
d'exceptionnel sa voix rauque tu as très
bien merci
ça va mon bébé toujours en prison
raconte avec moi partout mon chéri
j'espère qu'ils ne le sera jamais on va
avoir une vraie preuve de force et c'est
beau car qui va relever le défi je vous
le dis mokhtar ça va être très difficile
pour vous parce qu'aujourd'hui
mokhtar va rencontrer harry harry c'est
un homme qui tire des camions pas y tire
des camions comme ceci dit oui je n'ai
non ils tirent des camions et mokhtar
vous allez l'affronter on va vous
expliquer le défi dans un instant
regardez ce deuxième duel c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la micra 05 36 37
[Musique]
panneaux
les chéris le défi pour mokhtar va être
difficile il va rencontrer henry et non
pas à rire c'est beaucoup tard qu'on
entend s'il pouvait fermer sa gueule ça
en jette ou henry c'est l'homme le plus
fort de france
sachez le il est dans la catégorie de
moins de 105 kg et henri arrive à tirer
un camion je vais vous expliquer le défi
entre mokhtar et on rit dans un instant
applaudissements pas équitable
[Applaudissements]
mesdames
avait quand même au soir henry juste les
gars y'a quand même là quand même
le cycliste qui entendent pédaler ça
fait exactement 10 heures qui pédalent
ça y est 10 heures qui pédalent des
maynats henry henry qui est avec nous et
comme il est minuit les chéris il y a
d'ores et déjà dix mille euros pour info
je tapais directes 10 heures de direct
en votre compagnie les shérifs comme un
savant henry dans le micro dans le micro
ce meuble ça va bien alors vous comment
vous aident à chaque fois c'est vrai que
c'est comme le slip c'est vous pouvez
vous fait de la musculation à un moment
vous êtes dit je vais tirer des camions
pourquoi parce que vous étiez en panne
je ne fais pas c'est peut-être le gars
est en panne sur l'autoroute 10 et 10
mois et c'est quoi laisse tomber la
dépanneuse va venir dans deux heures
vient on tire le camion allait sévir à
un an mais sans et comment ça s'est
passé
non j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
stéphane belleguic était le champion de
france de strong man en 2005 d'accord et
il m'a fait découvrir ce sport ah ouais
d'accord donc vous faites des épreuves
toute la journée d'homme le plus fort
vous êtes l'homme le plus fort de france
en catégorie moins de 105 - 205
c'est l'homme le plus fort de francs
y'a quand même y'a quand même thierry
mon le relou qui veut faire la blague
l'homme le plus fort de france est à
dire le gars qui est le plus à fort de
france
non mais en fait on se rend compte que
le gars est relou de jour comme de nuit
y'a pas de répit quoi il est toujours au
look what on joue toujours vivant tandis
que moi je pensais vraiment à fort de
france
[Rires]
là on pardonne la terre qu'on est con et
vous qui avait fait 34 heures de radio
aux 35 heures mais est ce que avoir des
gens comme ça autour d'une table c'est
plutôt un avantage ou un inconvénient
non ça peut être rigolo au début ça
devrait bien se mettre bien mais ici
pour toi comment j'ai bossé pour toi rue
mais il est tard là non oui c'est vrai
vous réveillez donc en même temps nous
n'ayons et il faut la raison donne
qu'est ce que vous disiez vous réveillez
dans combien de temps elle ne veut pas
me coucher puisque je vais aller
directement intel à wade va vous êtes
avec nous dans touche pas à mon poste et
vous êtes avec nous le soir dans le
prime
ça va être beau voilà non levé tôt avoir
du boulot aux frictions des quoi les
voitures afrique sur une fois que s'est
lancé aulas
je me demande s'il faut pas les la
couche est un peu comme le vin est alors
mon chien henri le défi va être simple
parce que vous allez voter tout de suite
je vous rappelle qu'il ya cinq points
pour celui qui fait le bon pari et zéro
point pour celui qui se trompe c'est
très simple mokhtar ne sera pas seul
face à henry ils vont devoir déplacer un
camion mais qui va déplacer le camion le
plus vite
henri tout seul en le tirant comme on
l'a vu ou mokhtar et deux joueurs de sa
team de rugby en le poussant à oui
normal alors qui va être le grand
gagnant chroniqueur chroniqueur à l'isu
pouyalet henry pouvait mettre en place
vous allez rejoindre mokhtar garder on
voit notre tarak ses deux compatriotes
c'est par là ce que quelqu'un voit là
bas c'est un peu leur le voilà merci la
vie vite merci
alors on savait les chéris donc
chroniqueur chroniqueur champions vous
jean-michel penser que ces anglais ah
oui tu fais entièrement confiance il ya
une belle tête j'y crois bah oui
d'accord vous chronique est un vrai bon
c'est moctar va gagner je pensais avec
mes deux autres qu i hate avait
willémois y sont énormes
enfin pardon mais ils n'entendent pas là
non ils sont très costauds regardent et
attendent et on va les voir à côté
d'henri quand même parce que romario 103
voilà on est là où évolue le kit home
away avocats restent gros blizzard est
dedans
vous pouvez voir il y a deux camions les
chéris enfin n'ya qu'un camion
d'ailleurs c'est à ricky henry qui va
passer en premier il va tirer ce poids
lourds sur 30 mètres en un minimum de
temps va chronométrés et ensuite mokhtar
d'un poussée avec ses deux potes pour
battre le temps d'henri henry est ce que
vous êtes prêts henry à la retraite à
chaque fois il a l'air plutôt que des
potes attention henri mettez-vous en
place c'est lui qui va démarrer
c'est lui qui va tirer le camion voilà
apparemment il est dans l'expectative
actuellement jean-luc vous avez des kivu
jean marie france et henry oui je pense
tout comme jean-michel et si je me sens
à vous et nora vous un obtient il est
costaud puis les deux p'tits loups à
côté c'est un bon trio j'y crois à la
réclusion au fond du rugby en plus ce
sont l'habitude doigt la zone
c'est exactement
la mêlée oui comme on va le revoir oui
mais je lui donnerai votre adresse il
vous retrouvera le vol des vigiles
je crois en eux car c'est un compétiteur
rien lâcher d'accord en tout cas le
orange va extrêmement bien c'est gentil
vraiment vous êtes touchant et vous
isabelle ben je mets chroniqueur mais
henry me plaît bien moi ça elles veulent
te sortent l'instant non c'est juste
esthétique je vais mais je garde quand
même chronique est allé très bon allez
on va voir tout de suite est-ce qu'on
rit est en place des cherry s'il vous
plaît est ce qu henry est en place merci
j'ai l'impression que ça du bol bordel
est ce que nous dit peut descendre et un
de la régie est allé voir ce qui se
passe
merci les mettre tous en place allez
donc henry va mettre ce camion et va
pousser ce camion il va le pousser sur
30 mètres en un minimum de temps et
ensuite mon retard et ses amis attention
dès qu'il est prêt c'est bon donc c'est
bon apparemment il ya un conducteur
quand même dans le camion ah ouais il
tire le camion il ya quand même un gars
de dents en plus oui
ah oui c'est vrai terrien la gare
souvient combien de kilos le camion quoi
c'est combien de tonnes à sac à dos 12
tonnes soit deux fois moins
attention on rit qui se met en place un
bien entendu si on fait comment est ce
qu'on peut faire un peu moins de bruit
les chéris s'il vous plaît merci on y va
henry aux rives a poussé sur 30 y jeter
à mesurer on va au bâti il va tirer sur
les 30 mètres ce camion on va voir
combien de temps y met pour le tirer sur
des mecs et ensuite ce qu'on mokhtari et
ses amis
attention c'est parti ilike world away
on savait pas le but de l'accord s'est
fait qui la victoire à gagner
au point
ouais il est pour l'instant à 10
secondes il va vite ça avance mais
reprend rien ça avance très très bien
pour une auto trop vite j'aimerais un
camion de 12 tonnes
je pense qu'on s'est trompé un oui je
pense main d'henry qui va gagner
ah oui c'est cool et 51 centièmes alors
lancé le beta le gard oui la star et ses
amis
à mon avis ils vont passer pour des
tocards bientôt me fait un gros push ou
alors est-ce qu'on peut revoir vos
pronostics civeyrac ont changé non non
non non non non jamais vous aviez mis
chroniqueurs vous également
non j'ai vu son médecin n'avait dit
chaque jour c'est un non match d'hommes
xavier des chroniqueurs vous a dit et
c'est vrai non non non c'est philippe
unique est vrai c'est vrai mais à ceci
près non mais c'est fini safina s'est
révélé ce mot dire un truc anachronique
leurs chroniqueurs chroniqueurs ont
d'affairé veille oui qu'est ce que vous
vouliez a quand même quoi non j'ignorais
qu'il cédait d'une corde
on l'a vu leur équilibre mais qu'il est
con tu crois qu'il va tirer que les noms
mais comment vous voulez qui tire le
camion vaut mieux qu'une corde si on
l'avait pas les réparations ne les y
aurait plus juste avoir un harnais est
comme ça donne quoi jeter un con mais qu
elle ignorait aussi
non mais on l'a joué dans l'affairé
vidéo la vue de la vidéo voilà qu
essayer vous l'ignoriez non j'avais tout
compris moi merci qu'aux motards et ses
amis vont devra pas 30 et 21 secondes 21
secondes pour pousser jusqu'à 20 sur 30
m attention 3 2 seront à votre envoyé
les colis va aller
alors
les symptômes
c'est fait
[Applaudissements]
et
ces motards et ses habitants gunner
[Applaudissements]
10 4 secondes et bravo bravo lorie et
bras voire motards et c'est quoi tu dis
merci et encore merci les chéris alors
vous vous aviez dit avec chroniqueur
xavier des chroniqueurs ont un oui alors
crû en octobre toujours moctar a donc
cinq points puisqu'il a remporté son
défi
on va avoir un petit peu le classement 1
pour l'instant voilà alors bas c'est là
qu'est ce que c'est on est la seule
chaîne est là voila voila merci j'avais
rédigé de faux plat s'il vous plaît si
vous aimez là s'il vous plaît on va
refaire les points puisque il ya des
erreurs puisqu'un a beaucoup misé
chroniqueurs ont réussi on pouvait vous
vous réveillez vous faites tout ça et on
se retrouve dans un instant d'accord
vous nous faites le calcul des points et
on voit tout ça et benjamin alard on dit
ça vient du toit ouais
oliver bravo motard est motard et un
camion de 12 tonnes quand même encore
dit angelo quoi ah et en temps et en
jean mais alors quoi etc et avec un sens
mieux je pense quoi mais avec un petit
short hills a marché mieux mais on a
laissé bien voyons vous entendez
toujours il ya vraiment quelque chose
des noces moselle à 1 0 non c'est bien
mais ça ne fonctionnait toujours
tunisien dans l'âme bien sûr que jamais
alors si vous êtes tunisien dans l'âme
venez à l'émission demain j'ai pas une
surprise fond j'ai la surprise de votre
vie mathieu de langue mais non demain
s'ils venaient grands venez sur le prime
time
vous étiez prévu et bob hayes aimeriez
je vois vous l'ignoriez mais oui elle va
très bien vous serez là demain vous
verrez la surprise que j'ai pour vous
est ce qu'on a fait le calcul des scores
enrichi parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'ils sont complètement perdus ils ont
deux trucs et à additionner ils sont au
bout du rouleau
nourdine s'il te plaît nourdine origines
nordiques me dis que c'est en cours 1 on
marquerait que nordine n'a pas eu un bac
scientifique
[Rires]
non
bassam à dix points des points moi
est-ce que ça pour que je réussisse il a
cinq points alors qu'il a fait comme
s'il vous plaît
benjamin et mais s'il vous plais
refaites les calculs et on se voit très
bien c'est pas possible
mais quelle bande là qu'ils sont nuls
aulas bon les chéris le prochain défi et
dites-leur en fait et agile et moi en
tête avec 10 le reste à 5 jours de chef
d'état
vous avez entendu origines vous regardez
l'émission ça vous regarde et une soupe
ou fait le cul
si on va réduire
il est minuit dix on va te dire les
choses quand même nom mais savent à quoi
s'en faut un gars faut ce sont ces
fausses jean-michel à 0 et jean luc
berho jean-luc à 10 joe biden à 0 et
jean-luc à 0 aller les chiffres ils vont
leur faire
voilà en tout cas hashtag belle bande
dormoy librairie il est temps par il est
temps pour moi maintenant de mettre la
main à la qui fout là c'est moi qui vais
faire le prochain défi est ouest vous
vous rappelez notre partie de bowling à
las vegas oui parce que j'avais gagné
avec brio qua non qui chante avec léo
est avec vous réglez est ce que vous
étiez là non ça c'est leur image et ben
justement sur les images ne crois pas
qu'on voyait tricher après que j'évalue
c'est à dire une messe avec mon chéri
lagarde s'était bien monter parce que
j'en voyais pas vous trichez j'avais
gagné cette partie de bowling vrai ou
pas contre vous matthieu delormeau
oui mais avec vos règles bravo c'est
fabuleux de démocratie vous étiez prévu
sur le prime de demain mais c'est vrai
vous étiez l'un des meilleurs le
meilleur c'était moi non vous étiez nul
à arrêter pâte à modeler à 6,6 à non pas
du tout ah bon alors on n'était pas
ensemble à las vegas
rémy même dit que vous avez surpris non
mais pas pour les moulinois sur cette
rentrée dans ma chambre
belle surprise à l'uji rabbin bizarre
que vous soyez là et bien écoutez les
chéris on va avoir quelques images de
cette partie à las vegas et vous allez
découvrir
gaëtan gaëtan c'est le champion ce qu'un
champion exceptionnel de bowling 1 c'est
un très très grand champion six titres
de champion de france et deux médailles
aux championnats d'europe et je vais
l'affronter dans une épreuve de bowling
vous allez pouvoir voter dans un instant
regardez le prochain duel c'est parti
[Musique]
hp avec la 12 non je pars avec la route
gelée série un bon quart des belges
[Musique]
toi
oui
gaëtan gaëtan mouvaux est avec nous
applaudissements pour gates en paix là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la victoire des bretons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est gaëtan comment ça va bien quand ça
va bien merci à et ans six fois champion
de france et ça ça si froid sur le tour
de france de bowling gailleton merci de
là vous avez quel âge
19 19 ans a way cinq jeunes et un adulte
[Rires]
la démarche du mec qui éternue merci
gaétan st palais plein comment ça va
tomber mais ça va ça
mais comment devient un champion bowling
parce que normalement c'est un délire on
fait entre potes comme ça le week-end ça
mais toi tu as senti que tu avais un
truc tout de suite qua non du tout
d'accord mais non alors comment ça s'est
passé par hasard je suis tombé dedans à
ses bons échos catoire et j'ai continué
enchaîné depuis maintenant là et tu mets
des effets tout ouais c'est vrai parce
qu'on a on a fait une piste un mois et
je sais qu'ils vont faire le bowling
normalement une piste de bowling boxe et
14 m oui j'assume l'enferment dans mon
salon j'avais pas non mais je rêve
d'avoir moi je m'en fou d'avoir un salon
des truck series chez moi j'ai une table
de ping pong c'est la table à manger et
je voulais faire une mini piste de
bowling
ouais eh bien on va belle déco on va se
répéter comme si voilà on va s'affronter
tous les deux comme je souffre je vous
le dis ça fait dix ans que je fais de
l'antenne je souffre d'un lumbago une
hydre au micro leçon s'il vous plaît
merci au micro s'il vous plaît merci
il paraît que ça marche à l'antenne
merci vous êtes merci paraît que ça
marche en tête
quelle banque allemande sans déconner
pas dans le mien si tu veux non mais ça
marche il bien je peux plus vous
plairait surtout à 00h30 les shihri je
souffre d'un lumbago je vous dis
franchement donc on a décidé d'un commun
accord avec moi même que gaëtan aurait
un très léger handicap c'est à dire que
lui va jouer les yeux bandés
c'est léger franchement pour jouer
franchement ça se saurait et moi je vais
jouer normalement on va avoir tout les 2
5 ans 5 lancé celui qui fera le plus de
strike remportera la partie
gaëtan les yeux bandés contre moi les
yeux bien ouverts aux biens s'est réduit
bah oui à trop kravitz qui va gagner
gheit en bas juste attendait pour que
vous sachiez gates en est ce que vous
avez déjà tiré les yeux bandés
oui
non mais il l'a fait combien de fois
dans ta mis à mal par deux fois dans sa
vie pendant quatre ans je fais ça une
fois par semaine non j'ai arrêté mais
après dans quatre ans il avait tiré sa
une soirée par semaine les yeux bandés
ouais ouais entraînements et vous
faisiez des strikes ou pas non mais
quand même ces quelques points ah ouais
ah ouais à votre avis qui va gagner en
trouver les chroniqueurs c'est ça le
problème voisins plus champions aulas a
tout fait tout les rapides et bien allez
on y va donc et nora ou pensez que je
vais gagner
et oui parce que vous avez la niaque
matches valence où le dis je le sens pas
du tout gaëtan jean-luc vous pu parier
sur gueye tous et parce que je vois que
jean-michel peu ça et j'ai envie de
concourir pour le réveil avec lui
rappelle si vous l'envoyez qu'on est en
direct
celui qui gagnera celui qui aura le
mieux parier celui qui aura fait les
meilleures prédictions gagnera donc son
séjour au ski et celui qui sera dernier
sera réveil matin avec moi jusqu'à 6h et
devra faire dring dring toutes les
heures alors qu est chroniqueur penser
que je peux gagner
ouais matthieu delormeau au coeur
d'amour voté contre toi c'est pas
possible
mais je ne disais pas nager donc vous
pensez vous valérie bénaïm vous avez un
sale caractère vous allez pas lâcher la
faire non si vous avez un petit
caractère de cochon qu'il aimera paires
d'embouts jouez vous avez pas perdre ça
n'en fera jamais vous détestez perdre je
propose que son parce que lui il va il
va divertir en aveugle et vous êtes
mieux donc vous verrez pas les quilles à
quel point ce m ah oui c'est bien
favorisant sa femme et leurs moukhtars
votre performance des gars je crois en
vous un lacet motta orthophonie semaine
prochaine
kate est allée gaëtan on va se retrouver
dans un instant on va se mettre en place
tous les deux on va se retrouver dans
quelques secondes juste après cette
petite pause et geoffrey le défi face à
gailleton il y aura beaucoup d'autres
défis je vous le dis la prochaine
affaire le défi sera enora elle viendra
la place et doha vous devrez casser les
pastèques avec vos fesses a tout de
suite
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous les ché il est
exactement
00h27 série et on est toujours en direct
moi personnellement je suis bien je suis
bien qu'est ce qui se passe chez moi ça
tout quoi et lui va faire la nouvelle
pub gaultier ou quoi que sperian ce
niveau là haut il est fort il bâtonnets
de colas à wil a été pour eux ces
maquettes capitaine maclou captain
makhlouf allait manquer quoi qu'est ce
qu'ils en ont tellement gay ça ouais
c'est alors il n'a pas regardé le manque
hélas oui pardon là oui là il est les
céder dans un autre des liens mais ma
mère si mokhtar en tout cas d'être là
merci d'être avec nous les chéris on est
ensemble pendant toute la nuit
le savez je vous la croix pendant 35
heures et on a encore plein de choses à
faire juge aurait rappelé il ya notre
ami henry qui étaient là tout à l'heure
à capturer le camion et il vient me dire
en fait moi j'étais venu pour tirer le
camion mais j'étais venu pour un autre
truc aussi si je crois qu'il ya le
championnat de france on est viendra
nous en parler dans le second elle
chantera quatre ans de force tout ça
donc voilà face un bordel pas possible
d'aborder prépare dans un instant et
nora sera mise au défi et n'aura donc
qui devra casser des pastèques et ses
fesses passe à face à une haie
spécialistes et n'aura contre olga ce
sera dans un instant clé pour le moment
on vous l'a dit je suis face à galles
tanguay tamoul roues donc six fois
champion de france de bowling et deux
fois champion d'europe
mettez bien beau petit monde car je
voulais gagner tout le temps parce que
sinon vous allez tricher donc vous
gardez vos pancartes même pour les
comptes et vous vous dites sur qui vous
pariez mokhtar donc chroniqueur pour moi
attention les cherry on va y aller venez
avec moi guettant gaëtan donc on va te
bander les yeux on va demander les yeux
gaye temps est-ce qu'on a est ce qu'on
peut demander les yeux de gaëtan s'il
vous plaît merci merci qui s'occupe du
bandage de dieu d'ailleurs voilà merci
c'est la mer et bah merci les gars alors
récupéré un slip je vais pas je vais
choisir ma boule donc qui va faire le
plus de strike en cinq ans si entre gars
est on avec les yeux bandés ou mois avec
les yeux grands ouverts sur la vie sur
le monde je vais choisir ma boule j'ai
trouvé ma boule syrie j'ai trouvé ma
boule à c'est une boule à deux trous
mais en fait c'est mes boules donc elles
sont assez un personnage spécial est
normalement atamna d'autres boules alors
donc je peux pas prendre téboulba si tu
peux mais ça on n'a jamais pris tes
boules tu peux la prendre mais est-ce
que s'il vous plaît je peux avoir les
boules
est ce qu'on peut avoir est ce qu'on
peut demander les yeux d'alexandre s'il
vous plaît non vous n'avez pas lu bandé
les yeux avec un slip espèce de con
c'est quand même un monde le ghana
nigeria redoutera menace
mais on va boire en plus tu vois on voit
la meca les fils avec ton slip à battre
mais c'est pas possible trouver moi ça
va demander les yeux d'alexandre salue
toute la pub à madame mais la valse des
cravates quatrième cravate une cravate
dans public une cravate rasade là c'est
une flopée ouais ouais c'est ça alors
pourquoi vos boules ont que deux trous
alors n'a en fait y en a deux autres
aya de ce coup là je vais les doigts
mais finalement bien d'autres est-ce que
j'ai ma boule s'il vous plaît est ce que
quelqu'un qui produit l'émission
ah bon la ola moleux plaire en réseau
alors ce que je vois dans ma boule est
ce qu'on peut demander les yeux du jeune
homme s'il vous plaît est ce qu'on peut
se dépêcher alors sinon sinon je prends
ta brûle mois basée alors attention on
aura cinq ans c'est chacun qui va perdre
le plus de strike entre mois les yeux
ouverts et toile et je demandais si on
arrive à demander les yeux en instance
on n'arrive pas à faire une piste de
bowling on n'a pas trouvé un truc pour
la même voie les signer un bail à
l'écran non j'ai eu un tout petit moment
comme non mais là le cas il a droit y
est mais douce quoi tu payes sais pas ce
que c'est c'est pas la fatigue c'est le
stress parce qu'ils perdent y est
d'accord tu as peur tu peur d'être
champion allaient perdre et c'est ça
voilà merci c'est bon alors gates en
voulez vous voulez le faire en premier
je regarde après on y va on aura cinq
ans et il y aura une personne qui est
expressément là pour tenir les boules
voilà oui qu'est ce qui se passe me fait
doucement
à foix y aller doucement sinon va péter
le sol d'accord je la sens très très mal
cette affaire mais a beau y tenez à
votre femme anne laborde
c'est pas mal gaëtan j'ai pris ta boule
set mais je n'ai pas pris ta vie pour
gagner quand tu va tirer les yeux bandés
bande est comme la vie vendée comme
l'amour je dis n'importe quoi sous vide
il est tard le macitentan leçon celui ci
a les yeux bandés
tu es prêt fait gaffe au sol quand même
ça va coûter une fortune cette petite
connerie ce petit lino là ça va coûter
une fortune
allez on y va attention 3,4
deux morts derrière la déchetterie
derrière pour l'instant les gars ont
fait turquie repartir celui qui fait
mieux pour l'instant je suis en tête
gaye temps ci est assis le scratching y
ait un drame en afrique on le fait on a
changé les règles c'est pas au nombre de
strike sinon on va dire on va rester là
jusqu'à demain matin là et il me
rappelle alors est-ce que j'ai une boule
ou pas alors j'essaie de boules d'accord
attention on joue en trois lancers
d'accord 3 on va pas faire ses classes
et on part à 0 c'était un tir d'essai
alors comme ça et je suis fair play et
ça n'est pas mon sort non parce qu'il
est tard c'était pas ta boule saint si
si mais c'est pas grave tu joues avec
préfère l'autre bas les gens et je vais
être abattus pour la 9 tu me laisses tu
la payes pas prêt à temps ce quelqu un
cap à l'image ça se joue maintenant ça
se joue sur trois lancers celui qui fait
le mieux dans tout mon coeur
raté il arrêterait atterri kadress
pillay
il me reste quatre qinghai temps mettons
en place
tu joues les yeux bandés je suis chaud
[Rires]
c'est bon et qui sont placés c'est jésus
qui passe les qui merci jésus
merci jésus la france te le rendra pour
trop de dire merci tu te fous de ma
gueule tu regardes parents qu'ils ont
préparé un métier de médina promet
regardes tu m'as pris pour un jambon
je le vois le gars est en train de vous
regarder comme ça allez vas-y c'est pas
un point à point pour gaëtan rebrab aux
gars est en très forte
bravo gaëtan alors vous pouvez voir
c'est un bowling que voilà qui est fait
à cannes allemand donc voilà donc je
garde trop mettre les boules à la main
merci
le mec arrêts compris il y a un poids
pour toi alexandre 33% 3 lancé gaétan il
a changé de prénom au sahara et si tu
gagnes tu la voulais pas qu'ils sourient
pas que c'est de me concentrer je suis
au bout du rouleau moi j'ai l'impression
qu'elles sont mieux placés pour lui
salman arnaud face au dollar à zéro
pointé ça fait beaucoup mais moi j'étais
petite affaire le réveillant qu'on
aimerait c'est qui 5 qui abondent aussi
mauvais pas prendre parti comme ça je
peux demander un truc pour la prochaine
tu potes là-bas
brême a dû bien aller loin de moi loin
de moins bien cotées notamment si tu
m'as tu vois des concerts d'alain tu me
porte malheur
sarah galland et kate en règle on arrête
de faire ta tête comme ça là allez c'est
parti en trois points gagnants pour
l'instant y'a 1 0 bourgueil temps 2 0
pour alexandre 7 ans trois points
gagnants je fais gaye temps les mecs si
je peux vous donner un conseil mais
chéri quand vous rentrez dans le champ
des caméras de l'essayer plus de vous
cacher on sait que des acteurs non mais
les mecs veulent absolument se cacher ça
c'est un bol et ça c'est ma boule tu
vois ma boule elle est bicolore basse à
valérie l' attention si je perds cet
affrontement j'aurais perdu un ski à
diana s'il vous plaît je vais vous
demander quelque chose vous non mais
sans aller là-bas à aller là bas
voilà aller là-bas aller là là là il
faut que je sois bon d'achat
c'est mieux c'est mieux ouais y'a lui
qui alors là gaëtan un tu peux faire ton
petit truc trop regarder par le trou là
tout ça va pas être la même limonade mon
dieu dit on y va
il ya trois points gagnants ces bons
jésus tu es qui sont en place merci je
suis bon oui c'est bon pour les malinois
il me restait deux qui égale égalité
mais donc ce qui veut dire que c'est
celui qui attire en premier cas le point
les règles a été clair ce serait ce que
se sont déroulés non ce ne sont pas les
règles d'oubli et bas à mon avis j'étais
bien foutus de notre gueule je ne crois
pas que tu sois champion millar que tu
ne connaissent pas alors là on reprend
maintien ça c'est un bol
attention il y a toujours 2.0 pour
gaëtan je vous rappelle qu'on est
ensemble pendant 35 heures c'est 35
heures de bowling à l'égard de google à
son grave
aulas a pas ça passe avec les graves
dans les faits car c'est toi qui rigole
[Rires]
jean paul gaultier c'est lui qui rigole
ce petit mensonge grossier gauthier
aller mokhtar gauthier est jésus qui
fait un travail formidable j'aimerais
qu'on la police avoir l éclair 12h40 du
matin et l'ag du cayla qui nous a fait
une pique au bowling qui remet les qu'il
est pauvre il est au bout du rouleau
jésus tu es une bombe offert au neubourg
bras l'automne est là les crochets rires
non mais c'est vrai il ya des gars qui
bossent sur motus ils sont trois boules
à faire ils sont contents ici il fait
des qui dépistent et rue qui refait les
kids est au bout du rouleau gars gardez
il est arrivé c'est un playboy
aujourd'hui envers un dj king non mais
sa médaille d'or des banques est
toujours bon mangez vous allez on y va
thaçi qui abattent gaëtan si tu gagnes
tu auras gagné ce duel et je partirai
loin loin de tout ça vers le
massachusetts
non alors malheureusement on s'est
perdus puisque les qui ont quitté la
piste le rapport non on ne peut pas
faire tout et n'importe quoi
c'est donc gaétan gagnon
[Musique]
il est temps gaëtan excellent accueil
quand son beau c'est pourquoi cette
médaille aux championnats d'europe qui
vient de gagner les autres prix ont peu
partout mais qui n'avait pas les voix
centristes merci car étant d'avoir été à
la merci des cherry merci les amours
aller à la la la la la la
allez on va voir les scores et je vous
rappelle que dans un instant enora
cassera des pastèques avec ses fesses
face à olga et nora qui aiment les
fruits qu'ils mangent s'incruste et
légumes par jour et elle va affronter
une athlète ukrainienne qui a une
spécialité leur client tient le record
du monde de casser de pastèques farrell
pulvérise des pastèques elle a pulvérisé
3 pastèque en moins de 15 secondes
elle a le record du monde d'écrasement
de pastèques entre les cuisses
là mon record oui c'est un bon record
l'égérie pendant justement un qu'on
remet cette piste de bowling et tout ça
on va voir tout de suite le prochain
affrontement et le duel et n'aura face à
olga regarde c'est parti et l'orateur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enora holla holla lots et laura ça va
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez
elle aura passé le gard et no 1
je sais que vous aimez les souris oui
tout à fait je mets les fruits regardés
on est en train d'installer tout ça les
pastèques sont là bien sûr on offrira de
la pastèque à tout public les chiffres
après à la belle étoile à régler prenant
on en parlera donc la pastèque à tout le
monde la pastèque cassé entre les
cuisses d'enora médias la pastèque fait
ma taille c'est que du bon mois ne vous
inquiétez pas alors on va revoir on va
faire un petit point sur les scores
jusqu'à présent puisqu'il ya eu beaucoup
de défis est ce que les chiffres est ce
que les scores sont bons on va regarder
tout de suite pour l'instant c'est
benjamin castaldi qui est en tête avec
jamel et sachets sachez qu'il ya une
règle si vous êtes égalité à la dernière
place
c'est la personne la plus âgée qui sera
ré bay et bakol usages et ce avec moi il
va être réveil souvient du dernier
attendait le premier ça se joue a bien
sûr au chiffre unique allait oui voilà
entre général ils espèrent un bras de
fer
benjamins mais ce sera du cfu me ben est
pour l'instant façon on en est loin je
vous le dis vous n'êtes vous êtes
premier pour l'instant mais rappelez
vous de ce que disait céline dion les
premiers seront les derniers dans notre
réalité
oui jean jacques goldman les chéris il y
a
et nora illi à la personne qui va vous
affrontez qui est là s'appelle olga elle
et ukrainienne elle est avec nous à nous
fait l'honneur de venir elle vient
directement du cren elle est venue
directement d'ukraine en trottinette
déroulement d'applaudir olga
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais ouais venir
pour le gardien allait à la vache madame
olga dh où effectivement on n'a pas
envie de vous faire chier on se retouve
d'acheter alors je vais faire un petit
peu crédible parce que j'ai quelques
notions non calmez vous allez très belle
sera douce et minyana vous de syrie vit
aux tchèques ravivera grâce à ses bons
allait tenir ce message que je veux dit
qu'elle était très belle a fait les deux
seuls mots que je sais des rangs duquel
vannes
[Rires]
map
vam une ravine saint gilles verdez
gilles verdez banderas vite ça y est
j'ai demandé si vous trouvez beaux arts
à près d'un convoi est là elle comprend
ce que je dis mais c'est après les mots
deviennent pas iliad dont me yade ou
mais ça veut dire je vais donc tu as
safir elle réfléchit à d'accord est pas
mal
vous êtes jaloux tout c'est vrai est
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
incroyable alors on va on va casser des
pastèques alors en ukraine les pastèques
cd arbouze sahara vous sarrebourg ça à
roussafa bosser albi albi donc les
pastèques je vous dis si vous allez en
ukraine voulez manger de la pastèque
petites halles vous voilà j'ai
sarrebourg et donc et j'ai quand même 11
heures d'antenne relais patel et je suis
obligé de parler ou craignant les gars
c'est kremer ne veux pas me suis dit pas
la tâche
alors
je vous le dis olga vous allez donc
cassé des pastèques avec votre cuisse de
claude sarrail à debout ce putsch ou
nofoot ch
c'est ça et on va voir qui va écraser le
plus de pastèque en une minute jamais et
noël les écrits et n'aura elle va
l'écraser également avec alors je vous
le dis elle va l'écraser avec les
cuisses et vous aidera on les écrase ray
avec se tape cul seulement c'est
isabelle morini bosc qui viendra ici
elle va voler voilà pour vous faire et
vous avez mal aux jambes non mais pas au
derrière non plus je voulais vous je
voulais vous maintenir éveillé donc je
me suis dit préfère faire un truc
ouais hein d'accord mais je suis très
éveillé alors on va démarrer par vous un
gars olga vous allez donc essayer de
casser le maximum de pastèque en une
minute à l'aide de vos cuisses
d'abord les paris qui va casser le plus
de pastèque en une minute
est-ce que c'est olga donc la championne
ou est ce que c'est et nora et isabelle
morini bosc est sympa les mails isabelle
vous pouvez parier également merci oui
carrier merci oui parier tout le monde
mise sur olga renom mais j'aurai alors
que toi moi papa m'attendais quand même
un bull
voilà alors isabelle coup juste les
chéris c'est isabelle qui vous dérange
ou senora les deux vraiment le fait
qu'ils assurent la merde et du non
pardon j'avais mais non mais non je l
adore mais ça va
mais non et est ce que est ce que je
facture de machery tu peux arrêter de
dire avant ou après je les adore mais
non ça n'est dupe
alors vous pariez sur une oie merci
machine bah oui bah elle en fait partie
faites gaffe parce que vous pouvez peut
être qu'au réveil humains - et je peux
pas faut que ce soit 87 elle lie mais on
aura deux heures nous réveille je vous
le dis olga dieu bénisse déjà bravo pour
la personne est un gars vous allez donc
casser les pastèques vous allez vous
mettre ici d'accord vous comprenez you
are going to be here with the past
echos' thank you thank you attention
elle a une minute donc pour casser des
pastèques olga
[Musique]